super astuce pour votre smartphone de
Samsung est-ce que vous utilisez les
modes qui vous permettent de venir
personnaliser totalement vos moments par
exemple vous allez pouvoir avoir un mode
sommeil pour poser cinéma vous voulez
être tranquille vous êtes au cinoche de
l'exercice vous voulez prendre du temps
pour vous au travail vous pourrez ne pas
avoir divertissement bref vous pouvez
complètement venir personnaliser les
modes mais au-delà de ça on peut venir
depuis peu de temps changer le fond
d'écran façon automatique en fonction de
son mode là par exemple ici j'ai pas de
mode et bien regarder lorsque je viens
me mettre par exemple le mode exercice
et bien mon fond d'écran change et
j'arrive sur un fond d'écran un peu plus
sportif pareil si je veux par exemple
aller sur cinéma alors je désactive hop
et bien j'ai trouvé un fond d'écran qui
va très bien avec l'univers du cinéma
des pop-corn des burgers de la glace ça
me plaît bien et lorsque j'ai fini et
bien de la même manière je viens je
désactive et je reviens sur mon mode de
base je trouve ça extrêmement malin je
sais pas si vous connaissez dites-moi ce
que vous en pensez d'ailleurs dans les
commentaires